that's all right emergency evacuation
announcements in the event of a fire of
our emergency please exit the building
in order to you know an orderly manner
to the assembly point which is located
in the market carpark YX in this room is
indicated by green fire exit sign we do
not be laying yet the evacuation by
collecting any belongings do not use the
lift the premises must not be re-entered
until the fiber gave have been all clear
and please notice against the launch of
smoke on these premises please note that
this meeting will be either recorded
anything but our Mobile's come here make
sure you're live on silent or turned off
please thank you very much
baby evening everybody thank you all for
coming this evening first on the agenda
is apologists I have apologies from
councillor Eliot Mason substitute
counsel John Mason thank you counts
amazing for coming counselor mrs. Ben
wheeler apologies and use the award for
apologies other any more apologies at
all accept an apology use that don't
substitute non-members attending thank
you cancer Hazelwood are you are you
attending this adjust this up you just
sit down Lee and the outside are you
returning from any other non members
attending at all minutes of the meeting
here on the 27th of June and I okay then
sign them off yeah thank you members to
receive declarations of interest have
any no Thank You members number six
member Learning and Development Program
and I believe it
John just going to speak on it if that's
okay thank you thank you chairman to be
brief interruption
so this is the Midd program review
report paragraphs two point one two two
point five colors the mandatory training
courses that have been delivered our
grass three point one two three point
nine detail courses and other
arrangements held including by the
readability which the report appendix
setting up attendance figures to date
part four covers the course is scheduled
for October and November and part 5 the
parish training arrangements as adjusted
following decisions made at the last
meeting of this committee in relation to
locations and the recommendations are at
paragraph nine point one channel thank
you okay any comments members at all
please counselor mrs. Mayton thank you
as Thomas raced ahead three minutes so
the option of holding leave bullcoming
parish town council planning calls to be
explored and here we have a commitment
I'm not objecting to the commitment but
I'm just wondering where this committee
explores it and then all of a sudden
it's been decided in there to the pond
outside of committee perhaps we could
have an explanation
I refer you to 22 a minute and five
women perished ready
sorry item item tsunami to illuminate
and find quick one Paris train did
correctly father is ready
you know children that's probably more
about interpretation than than the
mystery reading is maybe it should have
said the explored and reported back
maybe you know it has proceeded in terms
of something at least the district being
being provided chairman yeah that's
about I interpreted it like that so I
may explore doesn't say to me to be
arranged it means to be explore is to
investigate is to understand the options
not to go ahead and implement there is a
difference between exploring the
implementation I mean I'm not objecting
to the actual decision because I'm sure
we would have made that decision
pre-emptive maybe but I only have been
concerned that a committee makes
decision which they seems to be expanded
without any apparent Authority so I just
would like clarification
thank you
John what with the previous arrangement
well I previous arrangements didn't
involve something more local for the
parishes and there was discussion over
at the time about including with the
parishes about whether something could
be arranged yes counselor Mason I want
to talk about something else
mm-hmm can we just
yes cancel family is theorem
I don't know but is there a charge on
the on the parishes if they said more
than one yes use always if there is them
it says there that the rostra parish
rooms are available on the proviso that
no charges made for this training to any
parish councils but why is it that we're
not using those I think what's happened
in the past I believe and I'm sure that
counseling mrs. Mason noticed we've said
this before that the the parishes have
been invited on many occasions to
training courses but never really taken
it up before now and I think the last
meeting we had led to believe as we were
trying to find an easy solution whereby
some of the parishes us or further out
so here so Riley would find it easier
maybe to go nearer like a may-maybe to
Rockford the the free house or the or
the Rockford parish rooms to do the
training but I do believe that whatever
training is made will be provided with
it was an outside of whoever does the
training has to be paid to do the to do
the training so usually we were saying
we don't mind
probably for the first person of the
parish of a parish counselor being going
at free of charge and in here self over
and above that all parishes have got
their own budget for training so it's
not no reason why not and we I have
found precisely to be a parish council I
was in pop clay a lot of the parish
counter didn t want to do the training
didn't feel it was necessary or they had
their own trainers in I just think it's
probably one of those things that we're
trying to compromise to help some of the
parishes to do some training courses
they wanted I want you to really yes
confirm that we have tried to encourage
involve on the policy at the moment and
I think it's an incredible one is that
one member from each parish is free
where we where we can accommodate them
and anyone else is faulty the parish is
often paying for other training from
other other sources so and they do have
but we have offered if you read the
report we have offered places for all
the parishes and the food and hygiene
and in the dimension frames and all
those nuns turned up to dementia friends
or one suburban hyejung so it made me
that the courses are not of interest to
them or they don't see it's applicable
the only one they didn't turn up so as I
understand it is the code of conduct
which we had nineteen but even though
those running from seven parishes so
we've got fourteen or sixteen and see
we've got reality around that numbers
again so some of them correctly then
it's at least you know fifty percent or
more didn't even sing one represented
the idea of having one representative
free of charge is that that
representative could then feed back and
educate the members of the parish but
also the clerk's of each parities do go
on alert I believe got another training
courses so they're there again to
support their parishes and maybe other
training as well in in them but again
we're here to help as many people as we
can in the parishes accenture so have we
have yes yes
I represent our DC on March 100 and the
question of training for the parishes
comes up almost every meeting and they
have raised this question particularly
with regards to having training in in
other areas so it may have come from
there although I take the point of this
is Kristine Mason I think that the
parishes will would welcome that which
please been outlined in the twenty five
point one was their triptych so just the
methodology yeah you know I just nothing
like counselor mr. spacely's we're
trying our best to get as many people
involved in the training instance we can
we can't lead them to a training the old
same about the horse to water acceptor
so it's just you know it's each parish
to their own I think really so it's any
other question on that at all counselor
mrs. Mason you want to ask at all or are
you counsel mr. John Mason you wanted to
ask another question
yeah I've become confused which is under
4.2 why I agree but the budget away day
isn't raining but I don't agree that
three point to the visit of the SS
police and crime Commissioner was
training it was a briefing it was not
right and furthermore the visit of the
success regime has now changed its name
from South in hospital as I mentioned at
all so I find it very confusing to find
the Essex police and crime Commissioner
mentioned as in its training but by the
same token a visit by this NHS success
regime is not so my nephew is the Essex
police and crime Commissioner was simply
breathing wasn't training at all so I'd
like to see that
that amended or at least the minutes
record the fact that it wasn't training
and that the South End
NHS busy equally wasn't playing
but he wasn't mentioned at all okay go
back on that counselor and mr. Mason
leave the NHS one was that the one with
it we was all in the big in the chamber
there lot of us was in the chamber that
time and then we had four or five
different people from the NHS but that
wasn't that wasn't trained that we
should briefing was the police I was I
didn't go to that one was another
meeting it was notified as a briefing
hmm how we go clarification on that
German I think it's just the report
traditionally like like this it has been
something by way of a presentation it
gets to mentioning in the report just so
all members are aware it's not suggested
that it's training in the in the way
they thought I was pointing out was so
if that's the case why is the
south-south M NHS justice regime
briefing you're mentioned either if he
if it's opened if it's normal to do so
why was that many anschauen I mean the
NHS success briefing question was
something that went to full council
formally and these minute heed however
again this report could and that sort of
thing as well you know well good because
I got the heading venture and that says
other things that were interesting other
than training okay yes again oh that's
what you want that's what you weren't
for unless you in the committee chairmen
it's not the meeting so what is that K
do you want to join hands with your
Mason again of them say that game oh
just a heaviness
you know anything other than training
that was interesting training program
today which includes basic training can
we better sorry
so minute in a minute sorry
transcatheter coming you have these
crime Commissioner maintains have only
open to the public this is a
particularly
general I could come in there and say
that the chairman of the of the briefing
did welcome members of the public
although I didn't know whether there's
anybody there opponent but they did
welcome members of public so I assume
there were coming there
thank you can I do it and the question
is the briefings in the NHS one and the
police commissioner one is the cost of
those does that come out as the budget
for training if there is a constant
nice to know under the e-learning come
on I just like to say that I did do that
learning module which I found really
interesting and totally different from
the safeguarding module that you do
really involved with scouting
I thought personally that it was easy to
follow I thought it was written in
language as well but it was easy to
understand and it covered
far more things that people may not
think about as being safeguarding issues
so I'm just a little disappointed to see
that the uptake on that from by the
parish and district councillors has been
has been love is that improved at all
since the report was written although he
still does feel like it's a shelling
because I think it's quite good it's a
good way of doing it and it was less
definitely less than an hour just to go
through it and answer questions and well
okay
counselor Troi Thank You Benjamin I
agree with that I think that some
relearning is perhaps the way to go for
the future but can I ask when the email
will come out reminding members to do
training yeah I'll get that done next
couple of days thank you Kevin I
continue to believe that elearning is
not the way to go 100% for everyone and
I think this is what we discussed as
something at the last meeting so I must
reiterate that I also had some pretty
I mean difficult experiences in the city
and commercial organization where a
learning turned out to be used as a way
of monitoring people's performance and I
have to say that on this occasion the
e-learning was monitored and they worked
tests at the end and some people didn't
do well the first time so they had an
ala go they didn't do anything
so they don't long ago and when it when
it came to assessing performance that
was used and I've got very grave
misgivings that in the context of an
electing person that is most
inappropriate and I want to see and
would like to see some assurances that
no data is being collected at all okay
is that noted John at all yeah I'm sure
the council if we're gonna if we ever go
down the route of e-learning which will
more in any way so it's not one of one
of the things we're going to you know
it's gonna be a that are just that
anyway so any other yes counselor nice
Mason thank you I'm just looking at the
attendance on the courses and also our
objective is to subtract it and to get
$10 home now
I'm looking at the planning of the next
six months and we look to I am in 3 p.m.
and yet so my knowledge all the
developments mandatory training have
been p.m. and evening there's not being
an AM offered and there still isn't and
yet where we've offered and I am on the
food and hygiene enforcement which no
it's not mandatory I grant you we've had
the highest attendance of any of the
other courses there so taking the
subject matter aside because we can't
judge how important or relevant the
subject matter is to individual
counselors we have to leave that out to
them I would like to say
the offer of a morning as opposed to an
afternoon is also extending to the
mandatory training as well as the option
of training I think there's something
that would be helpful but more than that
what I'm concerned everything worked out
the percentages of attendances on the
courses are we going from a high of
eighty percent to a low of ten twelve
percent and yet where that 12% is we're
offering two sessions which whilst we
want to encourage people attending the
training courses there is a cost to
these courses as accosting start kinds
of cost if we have to get someone even
around Sonic and there's a posting all
the time and travel etc I think the
committee might wish to consider putting
a minimum attendance on a course so that
if we have for example if I take the
treasury management hooks which was
offered for two sessions and had 12
tendencies I don't know if it was six
and six but even if it assuming it's
even equal split that's six percent it's
not particularly high it's it's a lot
less than 1/3 of the district council
members wish and I would have thought it
would have been sensible to consolidate
that into one session I mean we do know
if people have booked on two courses and
there's easy enough if we've only got so
many booked on one but I thought the
obvious is could possibly go out and say
okay we've only got so many other
anything that haven't booked
alternatively will only run one of the
sessions because that's what I'm
concerned and we're taking another time
out running courses with a very low
attendance and yet we could possibly use
that time to do an alternative course
with potentially higher attendance so
what I'm actually suggesting is that we
amalgamating the sessions when we're
there's a big
- no potential attendance and that
perhaps we can set a minimum amounts no
I'm not talk about the mandatory here
because obviously some of those appeals
nice to see there's a set amount but we
we consider a minimum amount per session
to make it viable yeah there's a haze of
Mansfield about I understand I think
what the first question was asked about
the the mornings or the afternoons I
think we discussed this last time I said
we're gonna do a movie or a movie in
more than an afternoon and I'm sure we
can do that again for the second lot of
it makes lots of sessions for the next
financial part of the year we haven't
done it on the mandatory we have on the
other thing used to being relatively
successful and again I think I agree
with you on the other on the other
school if we've only got five people
attending a session of doing training
you're right obviously that it's not
worthwhile but I do believe the officers
have done before if they have only had
about three or four so not they have
canceled it and said we haven't got
enough people to to train on that on
that particular on that particular
aspect but I do understand also believe
that if someone hasn't turned up then I
think the officers do it do it like a
role long where they can go down to the
offices in Watford and have a half hour
or even or now briefing with the offices
to do anything need to catch up on it on
the training side so that might be
something else we have to think on but I
think what we've got to do sighs that's
what you want if yes what you're looking
to do the gravely side depending on how
many online on a committee or how many
counselors are you talking about less
than half one more thing about the
voluntaries opportunities for training I
don't think we want to discount that
that we've got two sessions three
sessions and you've got eight people
here on two singers so we're running a
course people yeah someone mind if that
had been amalgamated you still have only
got twenty percent hmm no I haven't got
an issue but I do think that perhaps we
should look at something on these
courses and perhaps a level of around 25
percent and if it's less than that
perhaps the offices can put an email out
as certainly not run two sessions
because that means that you've got to if
you take the dementia friends example
you've got eight or ten days that's ten
percent per session excellent twenty
percent of the council attended which I
don't have an issue with but I do have
the issue with the fact that they're
running to set your session and at some
point in time perhaps three days before
we we perhaps will class obviously if
they see that that the numbers of
attendees is likely to be that low then
they can get cancel one contact the
people and you know can amalgamated
sessions into the most part for one I
just asked your sister she was making
accounts at your Mason do we used to be
do we yeah no that's how many are going
to attend a session and then they don't
turn up so we could end up having they
say fifteen attend you know ten people
turn up with that does that often often
happen at all John it used to be longer
to clear it we know things are looking a
lot we try and phone around and get get
get it get a sense of numbers but I
think the suggestion here for the
committee to use if it considers whether
for courses that have looked traditional
Oh consideration is given to American
lighting
and certainly something like the figure
of 25 percent but itself a membership if
that isn't reached by a few days before
the training then then it'd be canceled
with some rethink
well I would say that if you haven't got
25 percent on the session then
amalgamate sessions I'm not suggesting
that's all that we can sort of course
what I'm suggesting is that we
amalgamate so that would here we have
two sessions three sessions like these
two sessions and yeah the highest
attendance was 25% and that was my only
so I'm only concern on that would be
that if we've got an external person
well we'd have to pay them anyway if we
if we've booked them if we cancel in a
week week in advance or a couple of days
in advance that would be my only concern
then we need to know when they need to
know when when do we can cancel and then
that point of decision could be made
hmm okay can I take counsel John Mason
place he won't either
yeah thank you German and then I
certainly agree that mornings should be
offered to as many courses as possible
extending tomorrow having things with
regard to the Treasury training I think
it would be better in mind that the
there is only one committee that really
gets involved with Treasury review and
that's review committee so I'm not
hugely surprised that maybe there are
only 12 because actually there's only 15
on review so actually I kind of think
that was quite a good quite a good
response I'd be awfully surprised I
don't think it needs to I think it only
needs one session I also think that it
could be placed under review committee
as training more convenient
and oriented towards these kinds of
reviews and decisions that we use making
although make it clear that like what
other courses are open to all the
members so that's usually I hope they
use for the observation the I like your
observation about ketchups and I was a
bit concerned to note that the licensing
committee which is actually not that
large has two members who were unable to
attend the training so far of it and I
agree with you but there should be
offered to those members to fit in with
you know their lifestyle their work
their work commitments etc opportunities
to do some form of ketchup to ensure
that they are given the opportunity to
be available for nice to have hearings
and indeed any other committee meeting
considering gambling and licensing
policies and law as they relate I
believe John on cancer meds on that side
they were given an opportunity so it it
did come up that there's no we could we
ensure Thank You Jerry that the minutes
to record that back because the report
doesn't okay and he does look you know
just a little bit bold to say hey we've
got two men down or two to without two
ladies or bane undulating or or whatever
you like
anything else okay that's fine there's
no equipment so he can't see you today
with the offering the two training
courses and remark you made and
everything else he sees might be a bit
complicated maybe just awful one course
if he gets over subscribes we're not one
online minute I said we keep going
around I'm trying to work out is coming
I think I think what we're trying to do
counts is we're trying to make sure
we're not having four people to another
is the idea which one just to do that
but that's a good
Tiffany actually instead of an amalgam
and they've just done for one session
and then if there's a large demand
offered session later in the year the
second half hmm that's another
alternative to canceling it's just two
off the one session hmm
and you're not finding around funding
get people to come soon it could be the
core again that could be the case we
need four people in some of the first
session but well cuz it would take it on
board here we want to work this
counselor dry us sorry counselor as it's
been mentioned the three sessions with
14 that is district councillors in
addition to that you did have 19 parish
attendees over those three sessions so
when you're working out your percentages
I hope you will take into account if
you've got any parish that you don't
just look at 25 percent of district
counts and they're not turning up
therefore you will cancel one of those
courses
whatever all that you will take into
account parish counselors that have
booked on those courses because whilst I
can expect that you're looking at this
beauty from a district council point to
do as I say you actually had far more
parish councils attending those sessions
then you had districts young I'm sure
will they're gonna be taking into
account council yes council yeah thank
you Jim the to point to where we've got
it says there probably two members have
not met mandatory requirements and
obviously they cannot be substituted
perhaps i a time where a short course
can be put in place to accommodate those
those are two members for i know for one
fact that he's self-employed and he has
her son to look after as well in the
evenings and so can't always make
commitment on that and i feel that
perhaps we've been a little bit
heavy-handed and not trying to suggest
to him that perhaps he couldn't so
bringing into something else that may be
available to him at the time again clan
so i think this is what we've said if
they can't make it then obviously they
I've been asked they sure they can go
into the Botsford offices and be given
that the training course they need to to
make sure we women can come can we can
we not may be difficult I don't know but
can it be done in in on paper rather
than easy change indeed enough to run
his own business and I'm sure he can
read through any documentation so can
that not be put forward it can be put
forward by I wouldn't like to recommend
that but it can be foot forward but as I
say I don't know that you sure council
mr. May
well actually I think that's a very good
point because actually when somebody
does evening if as I recommended we
don't store data on performance then you
don't know you know how much has been
actually taken in from so called
e-learning in the same way with
e-learning be provision over other
powerpoints on you know which is
electronic to be read by the member it
will be just as just as effective in my
opinion can't see a problem by me not
quite so much with slices in China
because each council does their own
licensing but if people miss the
training closer we're doing my self into
the licensing Buzzard and otherwise it's
in cost point analyzers here by the
notes one of the tiny coral island just
to make it absolutely clear for the
record we didn't have any licensing
training when I was on licensing run by
this council at all in fact I was
invited to go and join the castle point
and actually it was a most enjoyable
opportunity because I got to meet other
members and also it was of another
perspective on on licensing so yeah I
really think that's a great suggestion
I'm sure that can be before as well yes
yes having sat through this for years
we're going back to where we started the
Magna tree ones are because the council
is at risk if somebody makes the wrong
decision and so the idea was we would
get the mandatory training for
wrongly as best as we possibly could and
then this committee would gauge where it
was working there's a danger with
anything you only need four guns before
you become a Federal Rule resolvers so
simply it doesn't mean to say you know
what you're doing
I'm just fiddling the results as far as
fitting other people need when people
take jobs as counselors there is a
responsibility I know they can run their
own company all of that comes into
believing you wanna see and obtain some
people you have to be educated to answer
the problems that come up when we didn't
have the licensing we had an individual
counselor who actually did not declare
an interest there was a Salvation Army
member and by the nature of being one of
those he was against giving licenses for
people to treat and it took quite a
while to point out to him you are in an
embarrassing situation and if one of the
publicans decided to put a complaint in
it would seem that the council would
rather bias in a peculiar way so I
understand the judgments problem that he
called it so long but we can't have
individual counselors all being fitted
in the best adjusting is send in to
another council so we have you on record
that years attended and he comes back
and says that was good or that was
absolutely lovely so I didn't understand
it when we get back to that again we
might not have so many people not being
schooled to sit on the committee but we
could have an embarrassing situation
that the press turn around it's like do
you know they're ducking and diving on
that mandatory thing I know I've sat in
at some of the planning from
and just with someone didn't like the
color pink they voted against the
planning now it's funny and so that
person for complaining and it cost the
council money but it wasn't the
council's money it was my money and so I
think we have to be careful it took us
ages to get the training in place some
of the things are there personal things
but you might want to do it but let's
get the first bit of life planning
licensing and code of conduct because
luckily we are one of the best Council
for that but we've had our clearly near
misses and we only need one thing to go
wrong and you'll get crucified because
you can't take individual councillors
because of their problems you have to
take a common sense can we afford it why
can't like turn up and really if they
can't do it they can't make special
arrangements because all of them were
one special arrangement so I would
suggest you step back and think thank
you very much for that yesterday was
very very good
yes cancer Stanley I thank the gentleman
argument seriously enough but I still
think that on occasions where and he
they know that they have commitments but
on occasions don't cover the commitments
come second to the family and we should
have a little bit of leeway a little bit
of compromise and I still say that the
idea of the documentation or for another
place to go in the means on when that
commitment that he has made to his
family or their family is he's taken
into account not saying that he knows or
they know that they've got to be on
there there
that licensing committee or whatever
committee is it doesn't matter we're
just talking about licensing but
anything and they make that commit
commitment and they've been there
several times
it's just happens that twice it's
happened where the family have come
first and I would always respect that
person to put the family first and not
to put any other anything else first the
family comes first my family comes first
before anything else and I'm sure that
everybody in this room their family
comes first because if it's if there's a
commitment that's the one you commit so
homely thank you thank you very much
counselor but some of the lower tendons
and it certainly affects me it may
affect a few other counselors I attend
some of these courses through my
permanent employment so I wouldn't be
attending the RDC run courses as well
that maybe two or three other counselors
that are in the same position might
contribute towards the lower attendance
figures thank you any other questions at
all
it's the committee chair so George - do
you want to make some recommendations
I'm quite happy to make a recommendation
what I'd like to do is do one with the
consensus this seems to be a general
agreement that the sessions shouldn't be
have to lower in attendance yeah I think
we've got two issues there one is a
problem that's being flagged up of
cancelling external trainers which of
course would or mind her costs and
council 4fd made I think a very
practical suggestion that we just found
the one session if it proves very
popular we can always win another
session there should be no increasing
cost there because we're not booking the
two sessions so I bow to the other
members of the committee how they feel
about it I think what we want to do is
to encourage people to attend but at the
same time we don't want to be running
courses that are not attended and if
rather than amalgamate is offered one
session or two sessions to be more
efficient if you like then I've got no
strong feeling either way I mean I think
so we use it as a recommendation of
councilor may 6th I think if we take
that on board now when the robbers
officers are looking at training horses
perhaps or look at it as doing a one
session rather doing two or three
sessions does that need to be a
recommendation or just that what does
that
I think the committee should determine
what happens you know rather than the
officers so yes I think it needs a
recommendation
you can decide chairman - what tonight
again sorry sorry John but again when
you say one session are you then saying
you want one session every single
training course it's coming up or you're
just talking about what what which one
are you talking about the manage of
training because mandatory training week
we need to offer that to the members of
committee and I think has been made very
clear we need to facilitate as many
members and accommodate them as far as
possible so that the committee's can be
effective and efficient I'm talking here
about the alternative courses of a
better word and we've had him I take the
current code of contact there was 19
parish counselors on 14 so but even so
two sessions would have easily
accommodated those the food the only
other one there was a member from parish
on was the food and hygiene which other
the high percentage so I think we need
to set a minimum attendance for a
session whether that is done by offering
one session or offerings home and
counseling one I think we need to leave
that discretion of the offices and the
costs involved whether it's internal
external and their experience on
attendance in the past but I would
suggest that we set a minimum attendance
for the non mandatory sessions okay
taking in cancer because the parishes
are coming along include those in the
figure I'm not suggesting that it's 25%
of council well 25 percent years it has
to be because obviously if there's 25
percent the council plus one count there
was a district councillor effectively
for those hmm
in that figure if that makes a
yeah I'm happy with that before I make a
recommendation on that that side I'm
happy to do that
yeah okay how do other members feel
about that yes counselor um could we
perhaps try it for a year see you know
we try these all the time every six
months my weight comes back when it
comes back to another you know meeting
like this we can change it again so so
if I try to formulate that into idea
that we recommend that the non mandatory
training program where the attendance is
under 25 percent of the council and
including counting the sacred
percentages and encourage counseled
attendings as a district councillor
effectively for that
the the officers are either consider
offering one session or amalgamating if
there's two sessions but leave the
discretion to the officers within to
offer one session or two sessions okay
pending on the cost and the
inconvenience does that make sense
I'm trying to give guidance things I
suppose the only thing I'm wondering
about whether there's a feel for them
that one to one session there's been a
lot of debate in the committee about
evenings borders is there is a sense of
you know the one session be an evening I
think very intense to do just by
appointment use the session that's got
the most people will come and say yeah
we'll come in a preview or common use of
on v6 yeah yes
and then in terms of it's been
discussion on mandatory training and if
someone isn't able to attend there's
been mention of training available other
councils and there's a sense that that
that's an option I think the only thing
I would say on that I won't necessarily
always be that option available around
because every council but I mean you
know so that's certainly something you
don't have to extend the recommendation
we could just say if a counselor has
been unable to attend mandatory training
and is out of their sessions perhaps
very week the council will explore the
possibility of them seeking a training
place on another council for them I mean
we know it that was so available but we
can certainly look at the possibility to
accommodate I think there is something
suitable to do it
yes I mean if you take some houses I
mean it counselor any class of example
works ship works and here has sometimes
it's easy for him to attend sometimes
that other people's employs allow them
to take time off some don't so there's a
great variation and I think we need to
encourage as much training as we can we
were making it onerous on council and we
can look at neighboring councils be a
castle point of Southend even Basildon
and something within recent moment I
think you can tailor it to the
individual I mean if I shake house three
basis it said well he works and King
might be sorry I'm sorry
okay so he could feasibly dream then I
mean other councillors like working
London I think I think we have to take
up the individual circumstances I'm only
using his in the energies so important
not as a proposal I can't stand here
today just doctor three years right that
perhaps another way of doing it is to if
a member of that committee can pass on
any verbal or any documentation for that
person then I mean I don't see any
reason why you know we have to go down
this road I do think that they'll mean
just to miss perhaps one or two s from
what counselor this is nice and said may
not be able to make it on that
particular evening may not because it's
work commitments or it's family
commitments or whatever or an emergency
and which leaves him pleasing vulnerable
so I think we need to explore those
other I think that's that I think I
think what we're gonna have to do we're
gonna have to try and and let's take one
step at a time
as counselor mrs. Mason is saying making
a recommendation because otherwise we
start going way out of what we're we're
looking to do and there's gentleman over
here is already said counsel over here's
already said that you know we need to do
these training courses and I don't
believe we should be doing either by on
paper or by Leoneans I've done
e-learning and I know exactly what he is
saying I read it once my know people
don't three four or five times to get to
school they wanted to and I know so
believe that would you know you you're
here to do a training course you can ask
questions of I are the other counselors
you listen to what's going on and you
can and and the person who is training
is there to help you understand what's
going on especially on the important
aspects obviously the mandatory ones are
are important but again it will take it
on board but let's let's go step you
know step by step and let's do one thing
at a time
cancel I wanted
councils for training and presumably
they could charge us for that training
and we could pro quo where they could
come to us if lightning counters being
trained I mean I thought they it's
certainly the case that there's likely
to be a cost associated with the new
arrangement it's also the case that
although more councils are seeing the
importance of magnitude training
particularly for licensing not all doing
and not all even have a committee that
deals with training so you might it's
you know as a constant it's it's it's it
is finding and exploring maybe they all
do Ansari or but in Essex it's a bit you
know there would be cost to the
committee chairman and I think but then
the numbers of relatively low I guess
Mason share was nothing we've we
forgotten is that any in the scenario a
councillor standing was talking about
somebody who is you know unable to
attend for very good reasons they
received the training material which
they can work through on their own and
ask questions
remember they can always make an appeal
essentially it's a training tribunal
isn't it I do know that a member went
through this whilst they were chair of
the Council and they went before a
convened tribunal who who has attained
that the member had undertaken the
training separately and was allowed to
pass into a voting category so that
member of yours can sustain you could
receive the material from the training
myth
could work through it at their own pace
ask questions of obvious is about it if
that's and go to a properly convened
tribunal of the council to ask for that
manager training to be to be waived for
them to be reinstated as a voting member
I have no idea never come across it but
I can I didn't want to okay I'll say
Council ugly when she was chairman of
the council okay she couldn't attend a
planning mandatory training and because
she was very fond of training and
particularly fond of planning a tribunal
was convened so that she could explain
her reason for excuse which is always
reasonable but it was also put that she
conducted her training separately and
her end and demonstrated her knowledge
of planning and was reinstated as a
voting member without having undertaken
the training per se that's on the record
it's on the record
they will be there's a we've got so many
training courses yes counselor what I've
been saying is enormous true they can
appeal and they appeal to this committee
we're not all counselors so it isn't
bias one way or the other but if there
is a personal reason by someone's missed
the training they can appeal and
arrangements be made for them to get
trying
and then it's up to that committee or
that group or jury to decide whether
they're qualified
there's been about two or three people
actually done that over the years it's
never been publicized that much because
most of them wanted to be trained and
they were making excuses but I think the
danger is that if you end up with
certainly especially the licensing one
there's been quite a few near misses and
you've got to be careful and yes anyone
can read through something and believe
they understand it but they've only got
to say the wrong thing at the wrong time
and there's no way back you can't cover
that up because they've learnt trainings
and they're making decisions and it's
quite obvious that a little clue what
they're talking about and then the
council's for that I do Belize has got a
hard one really and understand what
you're saying you know but again it's
like you can't if someone can't attend
train you may be Lincoln at the fete
they've given the opportunity to help or
do it somewhere else
anyway as I said that that let's let's
let's start with the first one it's a
counselor mrs. Mason wants to recommend
otherwise we're going to begin on
further so in respective in respective
non-mandatory Raving where the
attendance is under 25 percent of the
council and that's including time for
the sacred percentages parish council
attendance then you either consider
offering one session or amalgamating
promoting to the moment so the most
population to the most popular session
of the discretion of the offices that's
the first one yeah and that the one
session is not necessarily in
as an evening session and if the
counselors are not able to attend
mandatory training the council will
explore possibility of seeking the
training also elsewhere if there's
something suitable according to
individual circumstances that one
recommendation or to recommend a juicer
there's two separate recommendations are
we agree on that members shall we have
to do that over any comments at all take
a moment
do we need to take a boat recently I'm
happy I'm take a bug if you like failing
in favor one two three four five six
seven seven eight in favor okay okay I
think it's a voting members voting you
remember yeah okay so that that's that
you're happy with that now yes doing
those two recommendations
yes and I think the suggestion that wind
up puts in the next session aims for the
mandatory would be oh yeah that's great
okay and I think that's helpful I think
it will help going forward and hopefully
this will go on yeah absolutely
is there yet any other questions on yes
counselor on there are two other yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna come to now I just
wanted to make sure there's nothing else
before I came to the last two bits
cancer so Mason turn it off thank you
are we good about on the recommendation
of alternative explore alternative why
is to get that remember no we're not
yeah
so number nine the committee proposes is
to resolves number one so note the
attendance is that loaded members read
and number two to note the content of a
training program is that also noted
members thank you all very much it
20:28 you see me thank you all for
coming this evening
and 51